hootie-hoo yeah we've been listening to
your suggestions for people to beat the
crap out of Vin Diesel or Marvel
characters that want to get their ass
kicked by Vin Diesel either way we
listen your suggestion and here's what
we come up with for an epic nerve xxx
versus Captain America or how Vin Diesel
kick the crap out of America
I'm as always picking the side of non
comic characters and Adam is picking the
losing side no it's go ahead start
arguing for Captain America all right
well Captain America is you know Bionic
Lee enhanced I mean he's got it he's
he's superhuman he's the epitome of
humans you can't get you can't get more
powerful than Captain America and still
be a human and diesel till you realize
Captain America's only weapon is a
shield I don't know if you've ever
played a game shield or defensive weapon
no actually it's like just shoot now
round the shield no because I've ever
seen a Roman failings go up against
modern army doesn't turn out too well
for the Roman failings I've been doing
it in step 5 lately Captain America
shield is adamantium all right and he
can control it with his mind all right
ready no because Captain America done
Captain America has like friggin
cat-like reflexes he can deflect the
bullets with his shield and he's a
master with the shield you can't shoot
past Captain America shield it's kind of
part of what he is it's part of what he
is yes impossible read a freaking book I
don't really afraid of pickles because I
know physics I know I visit you're wrong
you know math English yeah not only the
only reason he likes Vin Diesel is
because Vin Diesel's bald all right and
that's the Oneg he gets the ladies you
what ladies have you watched the
pacifier there's not a single woman in
the past have you watched xxx
yeah I have watched my dues all control
when
did you see did you see the woman that
xxx gets she was [ __ ] hot yeah she was
the hottest crack [ __ ] I've ever seen
yes so so much so much harder than all
the time yet to see Captain America
getting a porn scene in a comic with
wasp with wasp a porn station X Amin
yeah I want to see them both naked
rather than eight on a bed there's
insertion
there's insertion my ass yes no no
because it's a straight get that that's
what she's my ass uh-huh no no no why
don't you argue why XXX would beat
Captain America let's hear this xxx is a
freakin boat so xxx was his military
advisor or whatever that guy was with
samuel l.jackson we don't need no snakes
on the [ __ ] planes samuel
l.jackson whoa wait a minute wait a
minute you mean the Samuel Jackson who
plays Nick Fury the guy who you know
organizes Captain America's events you
know the guy who kind of leads the
Avengers initiative Nick friggin Fury
now that's gonna be your guess because I
got a xxx he had a better haircut then
he didn't Nick Fury in Triple X he
looked like he looked like a burnt burnt
70s porn star no that's what I loved
about that's that a good luck you know
we're in agreement right no no we're not
in agreement Manson America wins right
yes
Captain America wins as zooming Triple X
is asleep and unless they're unless
they're doing the X Games because I Got
News for You you snowboarding down a
mountain and setting off grenades to
cause your own avalanche not really
effective against Captain America
because um it's crap I didn't I didn't
know that Captain America was immune to
avalanches here's another thing
oh yeah the shield protects them against
avalanches yes no no yeah no yeah this
shield is apparently like an all-in-one
er it's like The Slap Chop
okay well now let a slap chop a
defensive weapons Captain America has
already been frozen in ice once for like
50 years didn't do any damage to him
whatsoever what's an avalanche gonna do
annoy him 50 years nothing gives you
nothing you're right nothing and you
know what he do after the Avalanche he'd
be frozen he'd come back beat the [ __ ]
out of triple act well with this
defensive weapon oh then this one's
going to Vin Diesel no I have another
one will ever know indeed oh it's not
fair
in a couple weeks it's not over keep
posting your suggestions thank you very
much just do that
you
you